so first of all i just want to say thank
you so much for coming on the program
and sharing your story and
it's obviously
an incredibly emotional sort of
statement that you put out and i just
want to
give you the space
to talk about your story and to tell
your story
just before we start you still prefer to
be referred to as hear him or the
pronouns that's correct
yeah that's right i mean i haven't um
i mean as i said in my statement um you
know to be more accurate i suppose you
know i want to i want to be trans it's
probably a more a more uh a complete
description of where i am right now um i
am going to be going on that that
journey um very soon um whilst i will
you know still be an mp but obviously i
haven't started that journey yet and so
for the time being you know yes they'll
hear him and it's fine and that's great
thanks for asking and you say you want
to go on that journey
what do you mean by that well i would
like to uh begin the process of
transitioning um and i'd like to do that
as quickly as possible um i'd like to
begin as quickly as possible um but it
is a
you know it is a
um
it's not quick and it is challenging and
difficult and there's lots of hurdles to
overcome and um it's not it's not going
to not going to be done overnight it's
going to take many many years
and i think
now that i am out and people do know
i'm free to start that and actually take
that
go on that journey at a you know at a
pace that i i find comfortable i guess a
lot of our viewers will look at you and
they'll see someone in a suit somebody
who still wants to be referred to as he
him someone at the beginning of the
journey as she says yes
why is it that you feel that you are a
woman
okay so um
i
i have gender dysphoria
and that that is um
and i'm not a doctor but my
understanding is is that is the medical
diagnosis that is that is required for a
legal change in gender but it is it is
also the condition that that describes
that um
that um
this uh that
that lack of reconciliation between
what you look like and what your body
says and what how you feel on the inside
so um so that that's basically how i
feel and how it felt for a very long
time
i don't feel as though my body is is
reflective of who i am on the inside
and you talk about your body
rather than your clothes or your hair i
guess is that quite an important
distinction for you oh absolutely yeah i
mean for me
you know it's it's you know the clothes
and the and the hair and the makeup and
all the rest of it that comes after and
that's that's very secondary um for me
my dysphoria was about my
my my physical characteristics not about
anything else and how long have you felt
like that i can't
can't i can't give you an exact day um
but i i do um i do remember i think i
was i think i was eight years old when i
um
i
was trying to work out uh what this was
um because of you know that would have
been um 1991 1992.
um
and
there wasn't you know ready access to
the internet and there wasn't you know
anyone else in my community at home
that that felt like this or that i knew
about so i had absolutely no idea what
it was
um and i remember being eight and trying
to work out whether this was something
that affected just me or whether there
were other people that that that might
might feel like this
um i came to the wrong conclusion i mean
at the time i thought that it was just
me and that maybe there was some sort of
horrible mistake or something had gone
very wrong i think i'd characterize it
as um
as
just just a
a mistake that i was a mistake
and so um i spent you know i spent a lot
of time as a child trying to hide that
because i was very very worried and
concerned about what that might mean
um what that might mean if anybody else
found out and and and it was um it was
much later when i realized that actually
um
there are other people that feel that
way
um
not everybody will be thrilled that you
feel that way but there are there are
others out there
and um
and by the time
by the time i i realized that i had sort
of um
i had i had i had
tried to become this this person that i
thought i should have been which is
jamie which is this you know this this
this boy and bloke and man that was
going to go off and you know and do
these things and so
i decided to keep trying to hide it and
i decided to keep you know um trying to
um um
trying to sort of run away from it when
you say hide it
what do you mean by hide it do you mean
by
wearing clothes or doing things that
you're expected of of a man of a boy or
just pretending there's nothing wrong
what do you mean by hiding it well just
not not not dealing with it
so you know not not actually
not dealing with it in terms of talking
about it being honest about it
letting everyone around you know how you
feel
um and when people ask you you know you
lie
because you know people that you know i
was very careful about people that i was
close with and
sometimes
people would ask me you know maybe not
that maybe not directly but they perhaps
were aware that there might be a little
bit more going on than what i was
letting on
um
and you know in those circumstances you
would hide from it in the sense that you
would either lie
well no i would lie
and and and you would you know and i'd
actually
i'd actually say and do things to
strongly dissuade that person from ever
thinking or asking that ever again
that's been really
hard i don't know any different
so i don't know
um i don't know any different so you
know but feeling that
there had been a mistake
but you can't talk to anyone about it
and you don't know if anyone else in the
world feels the same way is that yeah
yeah um
you know that
i just remember being really frightened
scared you know i went to a great school
i had great parents i had great friends
but i was i was still
very frightened didn't think change or
did you still feel in that in that way
yeah i mean as as things you know as i
got older and i started to learn a
little bit more about this issue and
and and you know you come you you know
that moment when you realize that it
isn't just you
that moment is not just um it isn't just
a revelation that that
it is
exciting and terrifying at the same time
and why is it that changing
you know your gender is you felt that
you needed to do or that you wanted to
do
well that well first of all i mean that
that is the um
the the accepted treatment for gender
dysphoria
and that is um
what i suppose
on the inside i've always you know
wanted to do
um
and then you know you reach a point in
you know in your life where
you realize that actually
uh it is pretty foolish to live for
other people no matter what they may say
and
no matter what might happen
and you can't no matter who those people
are you can't you can't live your life
for them
and about a year ago maybe about seven
or eight months ago actually i am
i woke up one day and i realized
actually i'm no longer ashamed of this
must have been amazing
i'm not i'm not embarrassed i'm not
ashamed of it you know this is this is
who i am this is what i want and
actually
you know i have i have waited a a
a long time to to feel that way
and then um the statement i made i think
was
probably um inevitable once i felt like
that once i felt once i felt that i
actually accepted myself
then then i think it was always going to
happen at some point talking about the
statement and
it was an incredibly powerful statement
to come out as the uk's first openly
transgender
mp but there was a lot in that statement
you spoke about being raped
i don't know if that's something that
you're happy to
to talk a bit about
um
yeah i am happy to talk about it um but
um but perhaps i could ask you know what
what do you want to know
what happened
so um as i
as i said in my statement you know i met
someone that i liked and and you know
things started off quite well actually
and then
you know i i
was not okay with um
not being uh what i consider to be
responsible and and practice um safe
safety in the bedroom
and so you know i i withdrew consent and
um
and then there was and then
you know um he just decided that
that he was gonna do it anyway
um
and i was powerless to stop him
and and in that moment a part of me died
and i've been trying to get it back ever
since
have you managed to
no
i'm really sorry
it's all right
i
i think
what what is truly frightening actually
is after i said what i said
uh there has been a shocking number of
people get in touch with me to say that
something similar has happened to them
and um
and that you know has changed my whole
thinking um and and has has made me be
made me become
very concerned actually about the the
potential for this to be a much more
pervasive issue than than i think you
know a lot of people currently think it
is i mean the prosecution rates are so
low anyway and these are of course just
the people who come forward there'll be
many many people probably listening to
you right now
who
will have gone through something
appalling
and have decided not to report it well
i think it's that that that is that is
the you know for me something that i i'm
i'm thinking about at the moment a lot i
can't get over just um just how many
people emailed me and said or messaged
me on social media and said you know
uh something very similar happened to me
and um i you know those that those i
know well i have you know i have spoken
to a few of them and you know i would
say you know the vast majority of them
have not reported it and no one knows
about it
um
and that is really concerning because
because um
if you don't know about it we can't as a
society or as responsible you know
people responsible for passing laws or
devising policy we can't possibly begin
to get it right none of us no matter who
you are what side of the house the
commas you sit on
you you cannot get it right until we
have an understanding of how pervasive
this is
and that's that's not that you know
since i made that statement you know the
gender stuff is actually
you know just um almost to sort of you
know gone into the background but but
those emails i've received those are the
ones that
you know uh keeping me up at night i
just don't i just don't know i don't
know what to say other than
at some point we are going to have to
find a way of identifying people that
need you know they've been through this
trauma and need help i'm fortunate in
that i was able to go out immediately
and get myself some help and um
um you know and and i've i've had i've
had support and i've had you know
counselling and i've had you know i've
had help to deal with what happened but
but there are people out there that have
had no help i've never spoken about it
i've never talked about it
and and of everything that people have
to carry in you know we've all got
crosses to bear we've all got things
that have happened to us that aren't
pleasant but that is is something that i
honestly think no one should ever have
to carry on their own
and you our guests are in a position
where you have got this understanding
and you are
an mp you're a lawmaker
is it something that you
want to focus on
i think i'd want to look at it if i
wasn't an mp if i wasn't you know um i'd
want to look at it um you know i think
this is a societal thing um so i'm not
looking at it in terms of can i put a
position paper together or can i do this
or anything like that i am i'm looking
at this and i'm thinking
you know um
i'm doing the numbers in my head and it
it's you know so-called back of the
packet calculations of course but i'm
i'm extrapolating that out across the 67
million people in this country i'm
coming to some
potentially alarming figures i'm deeply
concerned that this issue affects far
far more people than we realize and
there are there are male victims but
they are in a very very small minority
the majority of people that have spoken
to me are women and girls and the
majority in fact almost
everyone in that that contacted me the
perpetrators are always male and if
there isn't a single circumstance it's
not like it all happened in one place or
in one part of their life or
you know it you know it it is a range of
uh circumstances you know some of them
it could be a romantic partner a spouse
or a boyfriend or an ex some of them it
could be a complete stranger some of
them it could be um
someone they trusted and and there were
others as well that withdrew consent you
know and and
you know you lose all logic when you're
dealing with something so difficult you
know as i did you know you you think at
some point you know it was my fault
and it it was about that before
i did you know and um i did feel that
way and a lot of people that have spoken
to me have said well i did originally
give consent
and i i i didn't have a reason to
withdraw consent and i'm thinking you
know
you know this is an intelligent person
who understands the law
but you can't help but feel how you feel
but you know um which i guess you as
well
you're an intelligence person you
understand the law and yet you still
felt
responsible in some way
i felt very ashamed ashamed
you know i felt very ashamed and um
which is
you know you're the victim i tried to
forget about it for a few weeks and i
almost worked almost worked but then
you start getting you know nightmares
flashbacks it starts occupying every
every one of your thoughts and you find
yourself just staring off into the
distance because you're thinking about
it again and
um and that's when i chose to you know
get some help you know i spoke to her
i'm a doctor and i you know a trained a
person who's you know that i've i've had
support from in the past
on other things and um
and um
you know
i'm not i'm not over it yet you know um
and like i said in my statement i'm not
okay i'm not the person i was before
that happened
um
but
i
i am at least
um you know in a place where i can i can
get on with my life whilst i am dealing
with it i just want to say thank you for
you sharing
what happened to you because
i do think that the more people like
yourself talk about these things
it's going to help an awful lot of the
people
who are listening to you and who have
undergone something similar
and you know that's evidenced by the
number of people who've reached out to
you as well and since you
told people what happened i did i didn't
want to talk about it and and actually
when i thought about this interview i
had no intention of talking about about
about the rape but
but
i think we need to do something about
about um we need to do something about
about what's happening but i think more
importantly than that we need to find a
way of
of of actually um
um
having
victims be able to come forward and talk
in some way and at some point in the
future i will be encouraging people to
come forward and talk about these things
and so i didn't think it would be fair
for me
to ask that of other people and then not
answer that question when you ask ask it
if me
in your statement you also talk about
being blackmailed i know you're limited
in what you can say
on that but i don't know if there's
anything that you
that you want to add there just that the
uh metropolitan police were absolutely
fantastic um you know i was i was in a
very dark place
you know
someone had um
got this information and and had
evidence of it and and they were you
know they blackmailed me um but the
police were fantastic um
they um
not only did they take it seriously but
they um they
they um
they got a successful outcome
um so the cps the police were you know
were really good and what was it that
you were being blackmailed about
my uh gender identity your gender
identity yeah let's talk a little bit
about moving forward and you say you're
at the start of a journey
you're not ashamed of being transgender
what are the next steps for you
i don't know
but i do know that you know i can if i
want when i want and so
you know
i've got a you know i've got to get on a
waiting list um because uh
it unfortunately you know it is going to
take a long time before i get that first
appointment
um i think some people around me were
concerned that um i might move so you
know very quickly it and you know it
doesn't quite work like that you know it
is a long process it is a it is a
transition it is a journey
um
and i can start that journey now without
without worrying about you know being
you know being seen or what people are
going to say or or anything like that
what's the reaction been like since you
said that you were transgender
uh i've had an incredible amount of
support um the the the whole um
the whole political uh community if if
we call it that the bubble you know as
they say has been uh has been very
supportive which is nice
it does get a lot of criticism don't
know they do get a lot of criticism and
and on it
on most occasions i have to say it's
probably uh deserved
uh but in this instance you know i had a
lovely letter off the lead with the
opposition i had um
i had uh colleagues um and for me you
know the um lizard roberts politeconri
we have fights in wales over you know
electoral fights and fights on the
ground so to have plyconrie to have the
greens to have the liberty dams to have
you know everyone standing up and
supporting it was great across the house
of course the prime minister himself you
know called me that morning
and said what he said and that was um
that was um
that was important to me actually
boris johnson uh has said
that he um doesn't believe that
transgender women should compete in
women's sport
is that position that you support
i think at the moment this debate has
just become very very toxic um and and
anybody that tries to say anything
um will be will be shouted out by one
group or the other and and actually some
of the
way in which this debate is unfolding is
doing significant damage to a vulnerable
group of people a transgender community
um look i am unashamedly going to
champion the rights and freedoms of
transgender non-binary people i'm not
not in any way gonna hide that
um as i as i have been before i was you
know before i was out
um but right now as things stand i don't
think it would i don't think it would be
helpful for me to start you know
commenting on the particular nuances
i think there's a huge amount of
mistrust between the trans community and
and other groups and and uh
and the system and i think that this
debate is being done in a way that is
you know is being done in a way which is
doing harm to some very vulnerable
people so right now i think what i'm
going to do is just
make it make it a priority to work with
those people who want to detoxify this
debate help bring that about because
when we all sit down and have a
meaningful discussion where we can
transfer some understanding then maybe
we can start to to get you know to to
have a proper discussion about some of
these things just finally i just wanted
to end by you know you've spoken like
really movingly about
your experiences when you were younger
what would you say to
a young boy or a young girl listening to
you and
i mean you're a very successful person
you're a member of parliament you went
to university you've achieved some
amazing things in your life
what would you say to a young person
you know grappling with some of the
things that that you went through when
you were younger
i waited
and and um and a lot of young people
right now i think um
um are dealing with with gender issues
um and my my advice to them would be um
you've got a long life i wouldn't wait
as long as i've waited i'm 37 maybe
maybe you can move a little bit quicker
than that
but um but actually there's absolutely
nothing wrong with just you know with
just taking some time and discovering
yourself and um
you know don't feel rushed to you know
pick up a label or you know or or view
it in any way but when you know who you
are and you're ready and you want to um
you know tell the world and assert that
there are people like myself here that
are waiting um you know you know we're
we're welcoming we're friendly and we're
here to help and support
thank you so much talking
appreciate it no thank you sophie thank
you
incredibly moving there uh by jamie
wallace and the uk's first openly
transgender
member of parliament talking
very bravely about his own struggles
with gender dysphoria and also rape of
course and if you are affected by any of
those issues i just want to give you the
number four rape crisis
which is
0-808-802-9999 that is the number 4 rape
crisis 0-808-802-9999